promo tip which I got from Tony Robbins
that can help you whenever you're
talking about the book you're holding up
and it's great that you have it as a
prop right and you got in the background
too you never say this book or my book
you say the name of the book so people
remember the book so instead of well I
wrote this book isn't it why I wrote
live life on purpose is because yada
yada yada right so people that aren't
asking what's the name of that book
again let's say about the book live on
purpose come on guys like this is how I
built my Instagram in the early days
well Nina was like going to Costco and
buying whatever I was sitting in the car
in the parking lot just thinking the
people one by one who followed me and
when I ran out of people who followed me
it was people who commented and when I
ran into people who commented people who
liked a message what a lot of people
will do is also see copies you can send
it to people in ebook form and then if
they like it they ask and also be hey
you mind giving me a review on Amazon
totally I'm on it I'm going to do that
like the next few days
in the house so you got you got a new
book yet
like trying to
use this to get more speaking gigs to do
more coaching deals is that you set the
focus on the e-book side so is that like
or is it is it selling the ebook was it
doing more digital like what do you mean
by digital where ultimately like do you
want this to to serve people
so really just to get the message out
there it's the contents in the book
which is a motivational inspirational
book based on my life and the things
I've learned in 30 years of not only my
career my life my running and my ups and
downs the challenges and how to be
resilient you know it's like like you
say many times in many of the videos you
put out really we it's through the
resistance that we grow and it's not in
the easy times you can never know what
it is to win and until you've lost so I
share those personal stories in the book
and really taking people up and building
that mindset the philosophy of personal
development and if they do it it just be
my just self-awareness if you're
self-aware you're ahead of most people
in the world because I think most people
are not aware of their potential and I
know who you have and I mean you want to
impact a billion people and that's
pretty that's a pretty uh tall order but
I do believe that you are on your way
because you have impacted Millions
around the world no question about it
but on a personal level you this is a
personal level you've impacted my life
now in turn I'm impacting thousands of
people's lives and so this book is
really to help people
um grow in personal development and go
for the goal with the plan and stay
focused to
tenacity and if they did that and not
quit when things get hard because that's
part of the growing process when things
get hard you keep on going I like what
Winston Churchill said when you're going
through hell keep going don't stop so my
book it's only 120 pages but I wanted to
make it really simple and easy read for
anybody to pick up and say and get some
inspiration and motivation for they too
can live the life they were designed to
live I love it dude and so yeah listen a
little author little author promo tip
okay which I got from uh Tony Robbins
that can help whenever you're talking
about the book
and and hold it up but it's great that
you have it as a prop right and you got
in the background too you never say this
book or my book you say the name of the
book so people remember the book so
instead of why I wrote this book because
I don't know why I wrote live life on
purpose is because yada yada yada right
so like you're not allowed to say my
book or this book anymore tip from Tony
Robbins you have to say the name of the
book every single time so it's like
starts to people so people that aren't
asking what's the name of that book
again let's see how they're looking live
life on purpose come on guys okay so
little bonus tip I hope that helps um
thank you to remember it too right uh so
is the goal like
do you want to get more speaking gigs
from this do you want to get do you want
to launch like a group coach program
like ultimately what do you want to do
next for Adam Durand this book is like
the the stepping stone too
are you talking about my book live life
on purpose so
I I am trying to get my book live life
on purpose out to the world and it's the
message behind the book and yes I'm
about to get speaking gigs of both I
said virtual and also in the physical
sense and just get the message out there
and a portion of the proceeds of my book
live life on purpose is going to go to
the Boys and Girls Club of America and I
it's time to get back I find I get my
fulfillment when I'm contributing to the
world and it's not about like Jim Rohn
says Tony Robbins Mentor he says it's
not it's I don't need the money I'll
take the money but I don't need the
money it's not about the money it's
about making the impact of my book live
life on purpose so yeah I'm trying to
get some speaking gigs out there now
he's going overboard
I love it though I love the immediate
action we love it so listen there's a
couple things you can do right I mean if
you don't need to monetize right away
the book what a lot of people will do is
also seed copies whether it's physical
like this like you sent me this right
um and that costs money for you to like
print it and send in maybe not a ton of
money but if you're doing it like times
a thousand then it's then it starts
adding up in the cost but you can also
see the ebook
and so I'm assuming you have a pdf
version of this yes right and so if
either one of the people you know can't
afford to buy it or two you just want to
get momentum for it you can send it to
people in ebook form and then if they
like it they ask and also hey you mind
giving me a review on Amazon
so that you start building some more
traction on Amazon
um if you can get you know I was talking
to
um uh the CEO of hay house and he was
mentioning that if you can get over a
thousand reviews on your book on Amazon
things start to really blow up and take
off for books uh so it's like well then
how do you get a thousand views on
Amazon well it's Gotta it's got to be
like 5 000 people's hands and they gotta
like it and you gotta go so it becomes a
it becomes a marketing campaign of how
do you get into as many people's hands
usually ebook is easier just because it
scales more unless you've got a giant
budget to just print off a whole ton of
these and like one by one and you know
you wrote a you know nice message on the
inside but you're probably not gonna do
that five thousand times for people
around but that that can become like if
you don't care about making the like how
much does this cost on Amazon to buy uh
I think it's 13 yeah so like if you
don't care so much about the 13 and
minus Amazon fees and all that stuff
um then that's the easier way to just
start building momentum around it
and start making a list like anybody who
follows you on Instagram any of the
people who have ever interacted with you
any any of the you know people you've
helped out people from the force people
you know entrepreneurs you've met people
through your running days you know like
anybody who you've touched and you make
a list and say hey I've got this book
it's for sale here it is
um as the first launch that that's
already through then I say hey I'm doing
a special it's a Black Friday it's a
Christmas special it's a new year start
your 2023 right like free copy of my
ebook uh or you're interested right and
you just keep track of who you know said
yes that you sent it to and then you
follow up say hey how did you like it
and if they like it hey would you mind
leaving a review on Amazon letting
people know what you thought because I
want to reach as many people as possible
and get this message out to the world
um and and you know hopefully people
will will do that for you as well so it
leads to more traction than people
discovering you so you're a small group
of however many people 100 people
thousand people whatever then can create
a lot more momentum around the country
and around the world because they're
leaving feedback on the Block on Amazon
um so that's why like I don't know how
much you want to pour into that but it's
a it's a great way to start like
exceeding books with your audience and
influencers and people that you know
even if they're not the biggest just
people that you know and asking for
reviews can make a big difference for it
to start taking off in circles that you
didn't expect
um does that make sense
totally I'm on it I'm going to do that
like the next few days I've already got
in my mind I'm I have a calendar I have
this
um dry erase board that I Mark
everything down I'm already lighting it
down right now mentally so I won't
forget okay but I want to be here
present before I get that yeah even more
than the physical book tour a virtual
book tour it's the seating and getting
reviews that ends up becoming a much
bigger deal
so whoever is coming to your you know
your book tour whatever or but again it
gets a lot of times the weaker
connections like anybody who's anybody
who follows you on Instagram how many
people follow you on Instagram
you know I got uh hats so I had a store
all over again I think I've maybe got
100 and something right now you got
hacked what happened I got hacked
thousands of people were following me
and I got hacked I did that link thing A
friend of mine I hit it it was done and
it froze it I could not ever access it
again it was done I wrote to everybody
yeah you were Adam what is it Adam
dossler underscore I know it's kind of
hard yeah that's a little rough that's a
little rough but okay we'll deal with it
uh okay so did somebody take over your
account are you are you yes they did
they took over my account and they're
posting stuff there they well they did
this is I don't think they're doing it
recently but they did that was my old
account and um okay so first I'm going
to follow you back so that's always a
good thing I wasn't following this
account you have 120 people following
you there you go that's 120 people and
you reach out to them with those it's a
video DM
times 100 like 15 seconds times 120
people you make a video message you say
hey John thank you so much for following
me I got my new book out live life on
purpose I'd love to send you a free
e-copy if you're down for it let me know
what you think send hey Susan Adam Duran
I just wrote a new book you know live
life right you just do that times 100
like all the 120 people for sure who've
who are following you right so there's
definitely something there to start with
some people will say yes great what's
your email you said in the book you
follow up a week later what did you
think and for the people who likely say
hey would you mind leaving Amazon review
to help me spread the message as well
right cool so that that's like step one
two is I don't you're probably not
getting that many people commenting yet
I guess on your videos and posts uh yeah
not a whole lot not a whole lot that
that becomes the next thing like but if
anybody so you've got people who follow
you but then you'll also get people who
who like your posts and comment on your
post and they may not follow you
like I didn't even know that I wasn't
following you because I guess it was
it's a new account right like you may
get people who then see your content and
not know that they're not following you
anymore because you know it can't but if
anybody likes your post or if anybody
comments on your post you can do the
same thing like hey Angela thank you for
liking my post like this is how I built
my Instagram in the early days well Nina
was like going to Costco and buying
whatever I was sitting in the in the car
in the parking lot just thinking the
people one by one who followed me and
when I ran out of people who followed me
it was people who commented and when I
ran into people commented as people who
liked a message
so if you look at your posts and you got
you know 20 people like the message cool
you know look at look at who those 20
people are and send a video message same
thing like hey thank you for liking my
message I wrote a new book I'd love to
send you an e-copy right so you start
building that up that's how we can start
to
generate some interest around it and
then whoever else you can think of who
whoever's if you have anybody on your
email list or people from the force or
people you've run with you just make a
list and get to as many hundreds of
people as you can think of even if it's
a really loose connection like the worst
cases you're checking in
and this is a great time to do it like
Thanksgiving to Christmas is perfect
because people are like they're winding
down the stuff that they're working on
they're in a great full holiday kind of
spirit mood and you're touching base to
say hi and most people don't ever send
video messages to each other so like
it's a great way to be able to do it so
that's one the second is actually
content so how much content are you
actually making now on this new account
I'm just pulling it up
oh oh I'm scared I'm scared hey Evan I
know you're bigger not a lot not a lot
I'm scared message you're right you're
right I
people have been on me for this and I'm
saying I was before on an old account
because I would get I guess that
dopamine rush you get hundreds of people
like hey great job Adam and then now I'm
like
you know I've spent awesome all my time
writing the book and now I'm getting it
out there I gotta get back and Evan you
I want to say and those of you who know
it know of Evan and you guys obviously
do people that are watching
Evan you are one interesting guy because
you would send me these video messages
even before I met you on a personal
level you said in these videos I'm at
work and I would see them huh is that
and you're like drinking coffee coming
walking back from Whole Foods or
something like that where you used to
live and you would just send me this
quick
you know blurb and hey hope you're
having something and I'm like that is
amazing I know you did that over and
over again and now you know hundreds of
millions of views later
there's the proofs in the pudding well I
mean the off the cuff stuff is even
better than just being most of those
videos I don't do here in my office
right it's it's walking it's outside I'm
with the dogs whatever like the diamond
is actually more genuine and more real
for people and it's easy to make you
just you just outside going for a walk
and you send them a quick video
um yeah you posted you post it twice in
two days okay that's good that's you
know good but then the last one before
that was October 28th Adam
you've got a book out I haven't posted
in a month this is this is uh this is
not what we need to be doing anyway so
one like it's fine I and I get it like
if you lose your account you gotta start
over it's it's a shot to the gut you
know but now we go and we we built you
know you go and you rebuild
um you're you're starting the race again
you know like that that just I think
needs to become part of the the daily
because your stuff was so Fire Man like
yeah you're you're energized especially
when you're outside and you're you just
finished the run and you're in the
middle of a run and you like you got
your your spirit going like that's great
content to share but the other thing you
can look at is once people start do you
do you know
um
but you have a list of people who've
actually read the book
yes yes I do and as you like as you
start doing the first strategy of
sending out ebooks to people you'll know
who has the book as well
you can have a series where you're
coaching people on the content in the
book
so whoever you send the book out to
you then make a kind of like this like
you go live with them on Instagram and
say hey you want to do you want to go
live on Instagram and I'll coach you
through figuring out how to live your
life on purpose too and then they come
on and they said hey
um here's here's uh Billy he read my
book
live life on purpose are you talking
about live life on purpose
it's so good dude so and then and then
Billy comes on and asks asks you
whatever
whatever questions he's got that relate
to the book so now we're talking about
the book
um but you're doing coaching from
somebody who so look one he now loves
you even more
because you spent the time to help him
Coach uh he's probably gonna tell more
people about the book but also you've
got content right now people watching as
you continue to build up the audience
keep hearing the book keep seeing how
valuable it is it makes people want to
go out it's like hey how do I get a copy
of that book so
content like I would do
uh if I'm you I mean I don't know what
the rest of your kind of daily schedule
looks like but I'd be looking at one
post a day video
when you're running or when you're
outside like it doesn't have to be fancy
formal suit
you know dressed up or anything just you
got your bandana on and your sunglasses
and whatever and you start outside and
you're filming and you go right every
day and for you that stuff is easy too
like your stuff doesn't you're not doing
like 40 takes and then like post right
like you're great at it and it comes I
don't know how much naturally it comes
but like you've also honed it as a scale
you've been doing this for a long time
and whether it's not just talking to the
phone but also in your career and with
the with the force and motivating the
the people there
um because you can do it so quickly
that should be a daily thing like for
you to record a 45 second message takes
you like a minute and a half to pull out
the phone press record it's not like
you're spending days scripting these
things out before you go up and do it
right so there's really no excuse for
not making games
this is so good yeah this is you're
great at it you're great at it people
love it and it doesn't take you long to
do it's like this is it's like it's like
these Doritos you know but if they were
actually healthy you know it's like it
it's convenient it tastes amazing and
it's good for you yeah I'll eat that all
day long right like that's Adam Duran
he's a healthy healthy Dorito so it's
easy for you to do it doesn't take you
that long and people like it so like
that's a that's a no-brainer
uh to go off and do daily content but
then an explore
a weekly series where you're doing
coaching with somebody and you get
people who've read the book and you ask
them most people dude it's like this is
valuable because most people don't know
what their purpose is and they're
struggling on how to do it and they're
they're living somebody else's version
of their life and especially going into
now or session Etc like people are super
scared don't know what to do being laid
off
it's like now is the time to go and
Chase down your purpose and so you could
be a helpful voice to guide people
through that transition
so that content's it's still pretty easy
to make it takes a little longer because
you're coaching somebody so it might
take half an hour because you're doing a
session but you don't need any prep work
they're just going to show up
and you say how can I help
and then they share what they're
struggling with and then you help them I
think it'd be really fun for you but
also give you some great content and
also help promote the book
so good this is so good and Evan and
that's why you're Evan you are Evan uh I
forget your middle name Carmichael and
you can do anything you want to do we
want more of Adam's motivation and
wisdom we look forward to his daily
videos
that's a comment says says Bertrand okay
we want more of Otto's motivation and
wisdom we look forward to his daily
videos I
was like let's go it's Gotta happen
and that is that by the way that
Bertrand that is coming from a coach
who's got one of the largest running
Fitness groups in the entire United
States that he's saying that and he's a
wonderful wonderful actually I ran a 10K
this morning called The Turkey Trot uh
San Jose we had over 20 000 people there
so yeah we're keeping this thing going
2023 is gonna be epic
no 20 19 was great 20 was even better
for me 20 21 22 23. put the sunglasses
on the future's bright it's getting
bright
I love it so that that's that's it man
that's what I would do I mean I think I
think continue to do you could do the
virtual book tour and the book tour
that's cool but you'll get the most
leverage out of getting getting the book
and if again you don't care about
monetizing it directly then getting the
book in people's hands get that ebook
out get get a hundred positive reviews
on Amazon to start having things like
you can make that your next goal a
hundred reviews how do I get 100 reviews
on Amazon do you know how many you have
right now I think 65 maybe oh okay good
5.55 right there's nothing then how do
we get to 500 reviews 500 reviews right
like hey how's their magic numbers a
thousand so if you want to just go for a
thousand and that's it you go for a
thousand like how do I get a thousand
five hundred or a thousand people to
leave a positive review on my book
because again then it says live life on
purpose yeah yeah that that book exactly
this is your most recent running video
October 28th so we're gonna do more of
these right but you got a couple things
here so first off you reply to one
comment but then there was three more so
we got to recite we got to respond
though to our comments here you know let
people know you know thank you for for
being here this is a good start but then
okay so here's the thing like you know
Angela she's great uh B Osmonds is great
always feel happy so I don't know these
people follow you or not right so these
three people here definitely you can
reach out to and say hey I'd love to
send you thank you for commenting on my
post I love to send you a copy of my
free ebook right
here
yeah like on purpose yeah yeah oh that
book right yes so you got three here but
then if we we look at here right it'll
say like by these people and others if
you click others it's going to show you
all these other people liked it but
never left a comment
so now you can you can message them and
say hey hey Nina hey Jim hey Diego hey
hey uh John Boy Hey Nando like those are
all these are all people who've liked it
but never said anything right and so
those are all people who you can reach
out to as well and give a copy of the
book and and dude you're barely getting
started like this is off of a video that
you're not consistent on and barely
posting so like now imagine if you
actually and I know you will because
because you're at a drink but imagine
like you actually start taking it
seriously in posting every day this is
only going to start to grow so it's not
a lot of times people struggle with like
how do I find people and how do I know
who to reach out to you got them all
right here man they're all in here
they're all liking you already and
you're barely getting started like if
you started doing this every day this is
just going to continue to grow and grow
and grow and grow and that becomes the
the positivity uh Army there for you to
uh get the message out and also get
those reviews
foreign
this is could not uh once again being
repetitive could not come at a more
opportune time and so I'm pushing ahead
I see the goal and it's not linear this
life isn't linear there's these things
and we you know get hacked or this or
that or whatever May throw us off a
little bit distract us but to get back
on that and just hearing that I'm going
all in I'm going all in the next time
one day we're going to talk again I'm
going to go to Toronto again to see you
or do some salsa dancing over that
Toronto dad Studio whatever I need to do
I'm coming and we're going to keep this
thing going because this is what we do
this is what this is what you're made
for and I know what I'm made for and
once people are aware of what they're
made for that self-awareness and start
to believe it there is nothing that can
stop them nothing I love it well the man
is Adam Duran the book is live life on
purpose go check it out and uh best of
luck with the book excited to see where
you take it
I'm very successful realtor and I
have started having people ask me to
coach them and help them and and really
spend some time in the lockdown thinking
about what the next step is in my
journey and
um I this year I decided I wanted to be
a speaker author coach so I'm writing a
book
um I've
um just got certified as a high
performance coach with Brendan's Group
which is how I found you by the way cool
and I'm just thinking about how do I
launch a thought leader career
um I fell in love with doing videos I do
listening videos that sell houses and
really love being in front of the camera
it turns out and so yeah so I'm super
pumped about building I've got a um here
in Denver I have a Denver office and a
boulder office but in this office I've
already built out a little maybe it's 12
by 12 room for a studio all right I have
gear purchased I have no excuses
um just learning how to get it all set
up I have acoustic tiles on the walls I
have light being on the way you know I'm
doing the whole thing and um what I'm
really hoping to do is put out video
content
um to start to build first of all
momentum for my book
um I was a millionaire before I was 30
and then I was homeless for six years as
a drug addict so um I have and I've been
clean for 12 years now so I have a you
know I have a little bit of a journey to
share with people and
um really interested in helping people
you know like you mentioned in your book
you know help people who've been through
the same thing but the same thing in my
case might mean somebody who's
struggling to make it as a realtor it
might mean somebody who's been homeless
it might mean somebody's a drug addict
you know all of those people are in my
core group of people to help whether
they're Realtors or
entrepreneurs I want to help them build
a business the way that I was able to
build a business which was really
focusing on the heart rather than the
mind so instead of top of mind I'm all
about top of heart which is all about
making real emotional connections with
people so
I'm babbling but the the point of our
time together here is I'm really excited
to learn from you uh I have a fear and
uh that fear is that is not to do video
my fear is that it is mediocrity
um my fear is that um you know I've I've
had some friends start YouTube channels
and put out videos and I watched them
put out you know a video five six seven
times and they go away and never do it
again because it's terrible because
there's nobody looking there's nobody
watching and I'm I'm a I'm a a high
achiever and uh I expect big things and
I'm afraid that I'm going to start
putting out video nobody's going to
watch and I'm going to go away so what I
need is a plan to stick to and if you
tell me do x amount of videos this often
for this long
um no matter what I'll do it
um but that's that's where I need is I
need some help with how to get started
great and and the target's going to be
real estate or or no anybody anybody
who's in sales or or marketing so really
which is you know an entrepreneur or
sales people I think that immediately uh
I can impact Realtors you know um if a
realtor hears that I've done 50 million
in real estate this year they'll want to
learn from me so I have a really good
soft you know audience right away
um and I have some people that kind of I
believe will follow what I do there but
I want to I don't want to limit it to
this real estate
got it so I would create a plan that
I would execute for all of 2021
and and you're not allowed to deviate
from it until you get to 2022. yeah
instead of judging like is it working or
not because it because YouTube
especially takes the most time to build
but is the most long-term brand building
that you can do because YouTube
is the only place for your videos will
live forever
right so we'll post you know this as an
IG live is great without some people
watching you see a couple some people
watching the replay but you know in in a
year nobody will care what happens on
your Instagram
five days later nobody cares what's
happening on your Instagram but if
you're if you're a fan of Brandon's work
you know his black and white video
series six years later are still getting
views still getting attention still
getting interest especially if the if
the content you can talk about is
Evergreen and timeless
so if you're talking about sales
principles as opposed to selling in
December 2020 sure right so I want
Evergreen kind of content and you can
definitely dive into elements of your
story I think that's fantastic
um three videos a week
you can fill them all on one day if you
can get to daily that's awesome but but
uh if you're a high achiever we need to
be over one one a week three would be my
kind of minimum in
um you can fill them all on one day if
you want you know for for a couple weeks
at a time so you don't have to
go into the studio or you know three
times a week
um I wanna uh talking head video
so you talking direct the camera and you
can you can pull ideas from whoever you
think is your biggest kind of
contemporary in the YouTube world and
there's probably a mix of people there's
nobody there's no one person who's like
you so I'd pull topics from Brendan I
pull topics from my channel I pull
topics from in sales I'd be looking at
Grant Cardone I've been looking at
Jordan Belfort if you're looking at
Robert Kiyosaki you'll be looking at
like whoever are the
your your bits of all these different
people go to their channels look at the
most successful videos that they've ever
done and then make your version of it
and don't don't even care what they I
don't care what they said so if you go
to Brendan's Channel or garyvee's
Channel and it's you know the advice
every 20 year old needs to hear
I want you to make that video
without watching what their advice is I
don't care what Brendan's advice is I
want grants advice so focus on the topic
take the title and take the topic
okay 10 minute plus video
damn it what
to sound so long it's okay I'm just
being honest you could you could do it
because you've you you've got knowledge
to share sure yeah I babbled at you for
10 minutes already so I'm in yeah well
Babylon is different than 10 minutes
right sure yeah yeah in in the book
there's there's the structure of how to
do a perfect thought leadership yeah
piece of content I would hone in on that
I I would guess you would be great at
your storytelling
you could easily tell a three four five
minute story or more your story client
story uh somebody you've mentored
um something you see happening with
young real estate agent sales people
addicts like there's lots of stories you
could tell I think you'd be great at
that I think the Practical advice piece
you'd probably be great at that too so
okay to solve this problem do one two
three step one do this and I'm sure you
could you've just had enough experience
you can you can even you had a point
form you could talk to those points and
be eloquent in in tons of value where
most people struggles is the opening
so you got to hit me with something that
you believe that that most people would
find different or weird
um so even this practice like what's one
thing you believe grant that other
people don't believe uh lead generation
is
great so like that's the first thing out
of your face when you press record yeah
the very first thing right so when I
work with people then they they still
press record and say hey it's welcome
back it's me Grant like no Grant yeah
right so you press a chord and like the
very first thing has to be a powerful
opinion that
like what did he just say yeah and so
that that takes some training to do but
I think most of the other stuff you'll
be great at
um so at least one video a week of the
three that is thought leadership like
that direct the camera talking uh I
would love to see one of the three be a
coaching video
okay where there's somebody in front of
you like this this is a coaching video
right but flipped so so now you're
coaching somebody who is in your office
is part of your fan group
um is an up and coming sales person is
an addict or is an addict recovery or
any of the topics that you deal with
okay and
the great part about that is you just
have to show up
there's no script there's no memorizing
anything there's no what's my first
sentence it's it's you just coaching
your your preparation is the Decades of
experience you have in this business out
and helping people so my goal let me
interrupt you real quick my goal is to
build a bit of a membership site and to
uh group coaching for certified high
performance so I think you've talked
about it this before so you maybe take a
snippet of somebody who's
um you know maybe there's a Facebook
maybe we have a zoom call once a month
um and I do some one-on-one in front of
everybody else for 15-20 minutes taking
a piece of that and just putting that as
YouTube content you know with their
permission of course you can do that
um and or you could do this
okay where you do it over something like
Instagram live to help build your
Instagram audience up or it could just
be a a separate Zoom that you do either
for pain members so hey as a bonus you
also get a one-on-one with Grant okay
right so if you sorry I'm sorry to
interrupt you but then do you take this
and put it back into YouTube
okay uh is that not all of these like I
have a Daily Show here not all of them
get cut for YouTube some of them if it's
really good it'll get cut my team just
decides of which one goes up
um but yeah so I go live daily on
Instagram uh and that helps the
Instagram audience and also creates
content for other potential platforms I
mean this this could get cut up into a
million different ways for different
platforms depending on what comes out of
it
um but that you could have it as a bonus
so hey here's my membership and it costs
x per month but if you sign up for the
annual deal you also get a one-on-one
with Grant
that then can be turned into content
right so you use it to you can use it to
get people into your program
um if you love it and you want to do
more of it then
uh maybe you have enough members to to
back it up if not then you can do it for
free
and people get to see you coaching so
that if it's free then it's public if
it's free then it's going to be online
and some people may not want it to be
public so say okay great well I've got a
I've got a coaching package and I've got
my membership program where you can
train with me every two weeks sure right
so the free gives you the attention that
then shows off you as a coach because if
you want to sell a membership program
where you're going to be coaching people
I need to see you as a coach
right not just a thought leader talking
the camera I need to see you like get
get the Ugg bug eyes like oh my God
grant I can't believe what you just said
that saved my life right yeah
um and it's fun you know it's fun like
talking to a person not just a camera
inside a 12x12 little studio right yeah
um and then my third series would be
something around the book
so how many chapters are in the book
um 15 16. yeah so I would take that and
to turn those into 15 to 16. uh
regular themes okay but then you cycle
through
so like what's chapter one in the book
um
I don't know I'm wrong or whatever
chapter seven and I haven't thought like
the one I'm writing right now is called
scraping the bottom so it's about
hitting rock bottom and just kind of
getting dragged along the bottom perfect
instead of bouncing off it yeah and what
what chapter number is that a seven
seven perfect so seven is scraping the
bottom and so you know every 15 16 weeks
there's going to be another video about
scraping the bottle got it and then you
just tell a different story right you've
got lots of different stories that you
can relate to you clients in the news
cycle about scraping the bottom
because I want you creating content that
relates to the book okay and then inside
those videos you can say hey and this is
also chapter seven
in my book right and it builds awareness
for the book uh without it being a hey
go buy my book kind of sales pitch every
time got it
um inside so those those would be my
three series that I would start with
that's awesome direct the camera where
you're pulling from the people who you
kind of look up to and respect uh
coaching with people who are in your
community uh and then a series around
the book
inside every video should be a call to
action to get something free first
chapter of your book for free uh bonus
video about the eight sales techniques
that can blow up your business
Howard became a millionaire before 30
like whatever whatever bonuses uh fit
best and you put it in the middle of the
video not at the beginning not at the
end but in the middle of the video
that then leads people to a landing page
and then you get their email address
because it's great to build a YouTube
channel but I want you to have a
business that's successful on top of it
not just your goal isn't to just be an
influencer right yeah absolutely so we
need to get people off of YouTube onto
uh onto our email list and then when
your book comes out then you've got a
list to be able to pitch people to
um if you want to add a fourth Series in
it would be interviews
okay
where you would try to get uh
Grant Cardone and Jordan Belfort and
Brendan burchard and whoever on the
channel do interviews and then you can
run targeted ads against their channel
to kind of hack Their audience to get
them to come on board
um even this like you could take this
interview this one-on-one
and turn it into a YouTube video and
then run it as a targeted ad against my
audience
so then people who know me they'll click
on it because they know me and then
they'll say who's this grant guy and
they learn about you and then dive down
your Channel
um if you want to add a fourth series
and then if you if you wanted to make
more then I would double down on one of
those other series I wouldn't double
down the book but I would double down on
either the coaching or the director
camera yeah if you want to go two a week
on one of those now we're talking four
or five videos a week
um again depends on how
committed UI and how serious you want to
take it but at least three of those
videos per week for all of 2021 and then
evaluate how we're doing at the end of
the year just like your mindset is where
I'm doing this three videos a week for
the entire year not oh I'm quitting in
February because exactly right yeah
that's exactly my fear how do I get
people to the YouTube channel like how
do they know it even exists right
because they're a gazillion YouTube
channels how does that
yeah so starting point one we're picking
good titles that are coming from other
channels right so that video on
Brendan's Channel about advice I give to
people in my 20s for example
um you may not ever have thought of that
as a title but you could give you could
make that video you know you could you
can come up with so we're pulling good
titles already the ultimate hope is to
show up as suggested against those
people's channels
um but Step One is picking great topics
that people care about because a lot of
times you might think oh I'm gonna make
a video on lead generation
but instead of calling it maybe using
the words lead generation sucks on
YouTube
maybe it's how to get more sales right
and so the content could be exactly the
same yeah but how you title it can make
a world of difference for how that video
performs that's huge um
two do you have an email list
no nothing zero okay so you know we got
to start building an email list yeah
yeah and anytime you come up with a new
video or series of videos you email them
the video so people can find it and I
should I shouldn't say zero you know I
have 150 people who saw me on stage
right before covid yeah are really eager
to do something with me and I've done
zero with them so great this is you know
it's time yeah hey the first 150 is the
hardest so yeah about 150 yeah you send
them links to the videos as they come up
um even better if you can put them
inside a playlist
okay
uh the link goes into a playlist yeah
I'm going to show you how I'm going to
show you a hot Grant this is great let
me show I'm going to go to my computer
I'm going to show you this right now
this is what you're gonna have to do
when you put out all your videos okay so
we're gonna go to Brendan's channel so
we've got the videos here uh and say
this one says generate energy in your
life okay like say this is your video
yeah okay
when you load the video here there's an
ID up here okay it's gonna go
youtube.com watch
question mark V equals and then this is
the ID of that video okay okay that's
the video ID
why this is so important is we're going
to go back to Brandon's Channel we're
going to click upload so we're going to
click
play all
and then this code we need to pull from
your list so up here you only have to do
this once once you get this code
we're going to take this says and list
equals
this giant thing okay
I'm going to copy that
okay then we're going back to his video
here
if I paste this at the end of this list
at the end of that link it's going to
paste it
what's going to happen is it still shows
me the video but now on the side it's
inside of a playlist wow so what's going
to happen is it says 284 videos
so you share this video
and then automatic is going to run
through 284 other videos from his
channel right and so if you only have
five videos it'll only show five videos
right but as you keep adding to it it's
going to keep adding more and more and
more and more videos in WoW
some people load the video and then just
turn it off like or they don't turn off
the computer but they go for lunch or
something and they come back oh I just
ended up watching 30 of Grant's videos
in the background yeah which all helps
with the algorithm people find out about
it that's incredible incredible now you
can also do this with other any video on
YouTube so this is this is um
okay let me find like uh let's go Grant
Cardone another Grant
so if I go to Grant Cardone
and we pull up this thing he did about
real estate predictions
so this is the video if you wanted to
share this video
you could take grants video
put the same Link at the end
and then it's going to put it inside
Brendan's playlist
oh wow so after Grant's video is done
we're going to watch 284 of Brendan
burchard videos wow
so for you if you want to share my video
or garyvee video or this inspirational
video that you found that's not yours
you then add your code at the end of it
and when that video finishes it'll just
auto start playing all of your videos
afterwards that's amazing
you seem to get that link once like that
link that I copied was Brendan's link
right you got to get your link once you
have your channel we can set that up and
if you forget I can I can help you again
to do it but
um
yeah it's like a quick little setup and
then you put that at the end of any
video that you're going to share if
you're just send it to one person and
look look what I did actually I just
left my computer and the brand video is
still playing
right so I'm gonna end up watching like
40 Brendan Bouchard videos because I
forgot that I left it open which that
helps again with the YouTube algorithm
um if you send it to one person it
doesn't matter like don't worry about
adding the code if you just send it to
your friend but if you put it into a
newsletter or on social media where
multiple people could be looking at it
it all adds up for the watch time
is you know instead of hitting my
audience over the head with another
email about me I can say you know hey
check out this amazing video from Evan
Carmichael but Carmichael but they end
up going through my videos after that
anyway yeah so yeah yeah that's awesome
and it the link leads them to that video
yeah so they don't have to click
anything else they're still watching
that one video but then at the end all
of a sudden they just get put into the
playlist that's awesome yeah that's
amazing so every time you're sharing in
a newsletter or publicly you want to add
your link
um and then third thing quick is I would
look at if you really want to grow
quickly I would look at a targeted ad
campaign yeah okay if you have a budget
to spend
um against different people's audiences
so on social or on YouTube YouTube okay
uh suggested video so video discovery
this pre-roll and Discovery pre-roll
means it shows up before somebody else's
video you don't want that Discovery
means it'll show up down the side
and so I would look at different videos
going to different people's audiences
okay so anything high performance
we're targeting Brendan's audience
anything real estate we're targeting
grants audience you know anything
sales maybe we're targeting Jordan's
audience or or uh you know like whoever
you think and it's got to be a big
player but if they only have a small
audience it's not worth doing
um anything entrepreneurship you could
Target my channel my audience and you
don't need access to be able to to do it
like you could just Target my audience
right now with any video that you've got
you just want to be cognizant if you did
a realistic video to my audience it may
not be as good as Grant Cardell right
sure
um and the little bonus on top of that
is if you get an interview with them you
definitely Target Their audience with
with those videos
um so yeah so you're consistently making
content with good titles that attract
attention we're using that link so
anywhere we share it outside of YouTube
we're putting people to a playlist and
then we're running targeted ads
um for each video that goes up with a
goal to gain views and subscribers a lot
of people when they do ads they just
pump up their numbers but it doesn't
convert to subscribers that's not what
we want like you buying a whole bunch
you could buy 40 000 views from somebody
in Argentina and you know great you got
views but it's not actually building
your audience
okay so I'd be looking at USA first but
maybe Canada U.S sorry Canada UK
Australia usually the other three
markets after U.S
um
and then hyper targeted for the video
you're going after again personal
development high performance Brendan you
just pick or Tony Robbins like those
topics you pick and you can just create
different categories like addiction
might be somebody else I don't know who
the who the leading addiction channel
would be
um
yeah so if you've got a budget it's a
faster way to hack the growth
that's amazing that's amazing cool
because I wasn't sure where to put the
video so and then do I take the same
video from YouTube and also put it as a
video blog on my website and It All
Leads back to the same place right you
can if you're gonna put it on your
website I would don't do it as an embed
yeah do it as a oh this is an even bonus
bonus so most people do it as an
embedded link right so you can actually
watch the video on your website
so you can like click play and they're
still on your website yeah don't do that
um YouTube
heavily discounts embedded views they
count for almost nothing they want you
on YouTube yeah so what you should do is
have the have a thumbnail like a big
thumbnail to say hey watch the video
with the play button and when they click
it it goes to YouTube
so leave your site and they go to in a
new window and they go to YouTube
and even even extra bonus on top of that
is that link also has your playlist code
at the end yeah
so then they're watching all of your
videos after
and if I'm any good I can have faith
that they're going to come back to my
website to learn more
because you load it in a new tab
right yeah so they have to close that
Tab and then there's your website again
okay okay so it's not like they've
really left my site because that's the
fear right
is that okay
amazing thank you
that's your 2021 plan sweet thank you
I'm on it I'm building it I'll be you
know yeah I'll be on our um I'll call
and I'll report back I love it all right
grant cheering you on man thank you very
much I appreciate it yeah take care see
you to see me coach another entrepreneur
one on one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there people are coming you for the
extra service they're coming to you for
the expert knowledge they're coming to
you for help you're going to tell them
all the things that they need to get
done they didn't even think about before
because you've been through it however
many times